sans humour hommage
est-ce qu'on aborde le travail
différemment non j'aborde le direct de
la même façon la grande chose que ça
nous a amené ses du temps pour
développer une relation entre le public
les gens se disent bon vin on apprécie
qu'on prenne le temps je pense que ceux
qui doutaient du travail essentiel des
journalistes projet chez nous partout
je pense qu'on est arrivé à la
conclusion que c'est un domaine
essentiel et où ne montrer que oui
sur les réseaux sociaux ou puis il ya
toutes sortes de choses qui sont
véhiculées mais quand les gens veulent
savoir qu'est ce qui s'est vraiment
passé
le réflexe est l'heure d'aller vers une
marque reconnue non je ne suis pas moins
dur envers moi même au contraire je
passe le privilège faire ce qu'on fait
on entend souvent ça mais c'est
tellement vrai faut être dur dans la
mesure où le public a eu droit à une
rigueur droit une vérification des faits
le droit l'animateur qui prend pas à la
légère en disant un peu n'importe quoi
là même si j'ai l'air détendu puis je le
suis contre le racisme
éventuellement on salue votre dernier
c'est sous son ombre
honnêtement moi j'ai toujours pris le
public en considération depuis le tout
début que je fais ce métier-là même
avant d'être chef d'antenne le public
nous a tellement envoyé de commentaires
jeudi à la blague souvent que je n'ai
pas besoin de psychanalyse à cause du
sport parce que j'ai eu une vague
d'amour extraordinaire
est-ce que je me permet plus de
souplesse oui je n'aurais jamais donné
des recettes de jambon avec sébastien
beauvais dans un téléjournal de 18h
parce que j'ai pas le temps non c'est
pas le temps de manger qu'est ce qu'il a
dit monsieur à ou de jambon à l'ananas
oui alors certains disaient que de toute
façon c'est pas très bon non moi je vous
avoue que tu commences c'est pas très
bon si vous aviez goûter le miel
sébastien vous vous aimeriez maintenant
le jaune et qui ont dansé remise mais
avec sébastian de développer une
complicité en ondes l'on se connaisse
pas si depuis vingt-cinq ans donc c'est
sûr que c'est plus facile puis en
confiant je sais que je peux l'amener
dans des coins où sera pas mal à l'aise
au contraire ça vole l'encourager
si jolie de voir des avions quand même
joli comme ça pour la petite histoire
j'en ai déjà piloté un nom j'ai eu à une
époque un brevet de pilote privé donc je
savais un bleu commencer je ne savais
pas je pense que cet humour là que pu
transparaître dans ses émissions là les
gens le voient davantage maintenant car
il me regarda 5h et seul j'ai envie de
garder
[Musique]
je souhaite qu'on se rappelle qu'on a
créé des vaccins que je souhaite que les
vaccins soit la solution permanente à
cette histoire parce qu'on peut pas
vivre une intensité comme ça pendant des
années des années et je souhaite qu'on
garde à l'esprit le sort des personnes
âgées dans les sièges 7 je pense que
collectivement on a le soir à apprendre
puis on verra la suite des choses merci
à mon équipe de feu en régime sur le
plateau merci à nos journalistes on les
a vus sur le terrain merci surtout à
vous de nous faire confiance je vous
retrouve au début de 20 21
avec le même engagement poursuivre notre
mission d'informer avec rigueur et
bienveillance
[Musique]